all right
again thank you for your patience and
welcome to the career master class on
cyber security trends and careers in
2022.
you have with us dr press aurora
is
azure cloud engineering microsoft
expert
in the field of cyber security
and before we get to
dr aurora i'd like to share with you
trolls for webex
just as a reminder
please put your questions
in the
q a
and we'll cue those up for
tesla's during the q a portion of the
webinar
and
you can also
send chat messages to all panelists
but we tend to take the questions out of
the q a stream
i also have polls
take a moment
get that ready for you
apologize for this glitch
in the poll
if you're watching on the live stream
just go ahead and put your answers and
i'll re-share my screen
basically asking your
general level of experience
we also asked how you're doing today
checking in with people during the
entire course of the pandemic just to
make sure that
people are holding up under the
infusion
so with that i'm going to go ahead
share the poll results
and today we have
an audience that's mostly
about half
people still in school
which is
uh good to know um
this is a after all a webinar about
getting into cyber security as a career
um but we do have
people from all ranges including
about a fifth of you who are
seasoned professionals with 10 years or
more of experience
so with that
i'm going to
[Music]
go ahead and introduce
dr pross aurora
in azure cloud engineering at microsoft
his passion is to help clients
create
safe and secure environments for
business operations
and keep out all of the
threats
and vulnerabilities that
come with operating in the
digital world
over 15 years of experience in cyber
security and in the past has been the
director of cyber security
with pricewaterhousecooper in india
and we're very fortunate
to have dr aurora here welcome
hi fros
hey stuart and thank you everyone for
joining in this session and thank you
stuart for introducing me as well to the
participants and i'm very confident that
each one of them has
that willingness to learn and grow into
the cyber security and i can tell you
with my experience it is not that tough
it's just just about how you take things
how you manage it and how you execute
that as well so we'll look at all those
aspects and
i am glad that i'm here to decipher some
of the
uh areas which
are probably concerning to you and so
feel free to shoot out your questions to
me and would be happy to take those as
well
yeah and it's
you know our world has changed so much
in the last two years
prior to the pandemic we were looking at
digital transformation as a major trend
in business industry
and
the
impact of the pandemic has just been to
accelerate that but that that means so
much more of our lives are conducted
online
uh in the digital space
which means so much more of what we do
is exposed
to cyber security threats right
yes absolutely stuart and we will while
we go through these uh slides in the
session we will look at the aspects in
terms of how the world has changed over
time and what it needs today to be into
this field and i already see some of the
questions being put up onto the q a on
the chat in terms of the experience or
the tools that they want to or they need
to learn to get in started into the
career from a cyber standpoint and
i can
tell you that during my session i'll try
to cover each and every aspect of it
okay wonderful um so if you'd like to
go ahead and share your presentation
absolutely
yes and let me know once it's visible
it is
all right perfect so
welcome everyone once again in terms of
uh understanding the cyber security
trends in 2022 and what it takes us to
get started into this field
and like i said i'll try to make this
interesting and very simple for each one
of us to understand what it takes and
it's not going to be that boring
all right diving into it let's look at
the story that we are stitching today so
we're talking about the connected world
that we live in
and
we will try to look at how it has
changed over time what kind of new
interfaces we have in today's world how
the technology we are using is playing
in favor of us
so what it looks like overall
and while we use the technology
it comes with its own perks and the
liabilities and when i talk about the
liabilities it's
going to be a big liability for any
organization in terms of
the impact that it can have on the
overall posture on the overall
execution of that organization
so
it is our responsibility as a society to
keep it secure and safe for each one of
us and that's where we are going to talk
about some of the specifics in terms of
what it takes to secure the world and
what we need to learn as an individual
to grow ourselves into this area as well
all right not wasting any much any much
or more time into it let's look at what
the connected world looks like that we
live in today
so
over the years the technology have
changed its shape
i remember my days when i used to go to
the school in the bus and i used to
sleep honestly because i didn't had
anything to do but now
my son goes to school in in the bus
a pre-kovitt time i can talk about
and he was all about discussing the
mobile games that he plays he's talking
about the new cars he's talking about
the internet as a technology he's
talking about the apple watches and
whatnot
and if i look around myself today it's
full of connected world
where we are using the mobile
applications and probably there's an app
for each and everything that we want to
do in the world so there's a mobile apps
there are websites
uh
it used to be on-prem or on-premise
earlier
now most of the infrastructure is
getting transitioned into the
cloud world as well
and we have
big cloud providers available in in the
world who can really support us with the
large workloads too
so the compute has
has grown enormously over years i can
tell you and
uh it is not limited to any of the
organizational boundary anymore it has
gone much much beyond the organizational
boundary and what we call very famous in
our office in our talking terms is that
there is no boundary now anymore in the
world
it is all in the cloud and not
not on the premise so that's what we are
talking about we have seen the messaging
grown into the environment and maybe
talk about messaging
it's not the email itself we can look
around whatsapp we can look around
telegram for that matter we can look
around the sms services for that matter
so the technology have grown multi-fold
over the years
now while it has grown multifold as a
consumer
it is on a fingertips for me to use the
technology but then at the same time
what an organization is dealing with is
a situation like this
where the organization is
surrounded by the clients they have to
serve so they they are priority for sure
they have regulations being applicable
or imposed on them so they have to
follow those regulations as well there
are there are rules they have to follow
there are third party suppliers the
vendors who support the organization in
this entire journey and these service
providers
are again having a kind of a complex
environment wherein they are supporting
multiple organization it's not one
organization or is not one is one ratio
so multiple service providers multiple
vendors clients regulators all of these
are the external entities to the
organization
now i can control my actions but i
cannot control the other environment
right that's where it becomes important
for me to tighten up my data sharing
infrastructure it doesn't become it
becomes important for me to
have a communication infrastructure in
place which can provide some layer of
security for my data in transit
i should have a supporting idn security
infrastructure as well so that my
overall data at rest which i am storing
data in transit which i am transmitting
and data in use which is being used by
my business teams
is secure so i need to have that
security infrastructure in place and
then i need to have the applications to
support the business users and the
clients as well
or for that matter even the vendors i
can have the interfaces for the vendors
as well
take an example of amazon
they don't have
anything with them other than the
customer base and the vendor base that's
the asset for them
so they have a website which is
amazon.com amazon.n and so on which is a
customer facing website or an
application and similarly they have a
seller.amazon.com for example to give an
interface which is totally different
than the amazon's retail store
and it gives a totally different view to
the to the suppliers or to the uh to the
wholesalers as well right so
they have different application
interfaces
for each and every external party to
interact and transact with amazon
now while we are talking about amazon as
an example
we have talked about dot com and dot in
dot fr and so on which means we are not
talking about an organization in a
in a boundary of a particular country or
a particular state we are talking about
in organizations
wherein there is no boundary
even from a from a geography perspective
so they are expanding they are expanding
internationally
and while they expand internationally
they are providing the global coverage
while they are providing the global
coverage
all the regulators now comes into the
view so earlier they used to handle or
follow the regulations of the land where
they are operating where they have kind
of established themselves but now
while they are doing the business
globally they have the regulations and
the regulators acting on them
at a global level
so look at the complexity of
doing a one change in the environment
the organization has really
a job to think about what impact it will
have in india what it what impact it
will have in
european union what impact it will have
in the us
and so on
so there are a lot of
intersections there right so the
regulations play a very big role there
now
it's not only the regulations
which drives the organization it's also
about the frameworks and the standards
that they follow
now i am an organization which want to
provide
a world-class service and a trusted
service to my customers
i would follow the regulations because
that's a need
but my want is to provide a much more
secure and a safer service to my
consumer
i would then expand my horizon and i
will go to a frameworks i will adopt the
security frameworks like nisd
i will go with the certifications with
the standards to the likes of iso 27001
pci dss and whatnot
so i will
make sure that my environment is
foolproof
whatever is the best available as a
guideline in the organization i am
implementing those controls and making
sure that i'm away staying away from the
breaches as well
now when we talk about the breaches
those are not the easiest of the ones to
handle i can tell you with my experience
being into a cyber forensics domain as
well
with verizon earlier
it is not easy for any organization to
consume
but on the contrary what it takes to
breach an organization so when we look
at that contrast
it is not at all difficult now
you can go on to the dark web and dark
web by the way is available on the
mobile again so you can browse the dark
web on your mobile device you can pay a
hacker or you can rent a hacker
to do a particular task
and you don't need to know anything
about it
they don't know you you don't know them
is just about a bitcoin or the
cryptocurrency that they are dealing
with
so you pay them and they will get the
work done for you
now while you can rent a hacker
but you are technology enthusiast and
you want to do stuff with your own hands
you don't have to code you don't have to
learn how to code
you just have to pay
a hacker probably who is already there
or a developer who is already there on
the dark web pay them get the exploit
get the tools that you need which are
not available on the internet otherwise
get those
exploits and then
find your target
so
that's the level of threats that's the
level of the threat actors the
organizations are facing day in and day
out
you need a service go on to the dark web
take that service and voila you're done
with that right so
so for an organization
to be secure and safe
they have to be successful every single
time
for an attacker
they just have to be successful only one
single time
and that's the difference that's a
contrast between what an attacker or a
hacker is
and what the threats organizations face
these days
so we are talking about
the competition between the threat
actors we are talking about a
competition between the motivation
of these threat actors as well
but do we see or do we feel that it's
only an individual or this the
motivation is always money the answer is
no
there's a lot more that goes behind it
so when we look at the adversaries
we are talking about the nation states
you're talking about the organized
crimes as well we're talking about the
activities which can be attributed to an
activist activities as well we're
talking about the insider threats
when we look at the motives
the motives is not money all the time
it can be economic it can be political
military advantage financial gains
social change
uh personal advantage personal vendetta
monetary gain and professional revenge
these can be some of the motives
that can act against the organization
and that can motivate the threat actors
as well
when we look at the targets for that
matter
the targets are
the organizations the targets are the
individuals but the what they need out
of it
right so they are talking about or they
are focusing on the trade secrets for
that matter they are talking about the
sensitive business information that they
want to exp that they want to exploit or
extract to work for them
as a nation state they are talking about
the critical infrastructure specifically
in the field of manufacturing all the or
the oil and gas sector
where a damage to a particular plant can
be devastating not only at an economical
level but also at the at a
personal lives level as well as a human
life
right we are talking about a medical
facility or a healthcare
sector where
a change in a pacemaker can really
literally take a life of an individual
so those can be the targets we are
talking about
the financial frauds we are talking
about uh something to do with the
payment card information
i myself has faced at least a couple of
times
a fraud against my american express card
and honestly because it was american
express i was able to save a lot of
money there
but
there was time when i was sleeping and
there was a charge that executed on my
account
and that that happened somewhere in
thailand
and i was sitting in india so
look at the the impact that it can have
and the hackers or the attackers are
very smart they would profile the target
so well that at this point
paris would be sleeping so let's and he
would obviously not notice an sms of a
transaction at this time so let's target
the individual during a time when the
person is sleeping
so the profiling of a target happens in
such a way that
it acts against an individual or against
an organization or against the
government as well
so the targets are
not only the humans targets can be
anything related to a asset that an
organization or an individual has
what impact it can cause
national security the biggest of the
impact that can happen when the
adversary is the nation state look at
the disruption to the critical
infrastructure
the consumer or the
shareholder lawsuits can be there when
when there is an organized crime
we will as we move forward in the slides
uh we will look at some of the events or
some of the breaches that has happened
in the past
and i was
an investigator of one of the breach
that happened
in the early 20 i mean early these years
i would say after 2010 so 2012 2013 the
breach happened
and the breach made it to the news as
well it was a big breeze that happened
in india
i was an investigator on on that breach
and i can tell you
it was
not easy for an organization to face the
breaches
and we will look at some of the
disruptions that can happen but
i have seen a ceo of an organization
sitting in front of an of a regulator
with the folded hands and asking for an
apology because
the ceo was not able to safeguard the
interest of the consumer
same thing happened with the facebook
wherein we have seen multiple lawsuits
being
filed against the organization for the
cambridge analytica breach that happened
and it was
really the mark has to go in front of
the senators sit there
and accept the apology and there's
he he
admitted that it was his mistake and he
should have taken a better cognizance of
a situation at that time
and secured the interest of the other
consumers or the platform users
uh in using the facebook
and they have come a long way they have
walked the journey in a decent pace that
way
so the impact can be on the organization
repute as well
and once the organization reputes
the repute goes for an impact
the impact can be seen directly on the
on the share prices of the organization
as well so the impact can be financial
impact can be non-financial as well and
we will look at some of those impact as
well as we move forward in our journey
so we have seen some threats now
it doesn't it is not what it looks like
at the face of it
uh
and let's look at some of the breaches
that has happened and
which has made to the news in a big big
way
and
to start with in the number one i have
this sony breach that happened in
november 2014
where the confidential data from the
sony pictures was released
now what happened when a pre-released or
not released movie gets to the
release or gets open over the internet
you lose a lot of money you lose rights
you you lose
about billions and trillions of dollars
as well
right and not only this
there was a lot of personal information
about employees the salary of employees
the email conversation between the
individuals in the organization
the executive salaries all that
information also went into a public
domain
and when i say public domain it was
literally there for everybody to
download
so
that's a level of information or the
breach that happened with sony
entertainment
now when we look at this particular
breach what exactly went wrong what was
the learning out of it
there were traces of the patterns of the
fishing attempts that were discovered so
multiple emails being shot out to
multiple individuals in the organization
it can be a spare fishing it can be a
literally a spray fishing attack as well
so the phishing attempts happen did
happen
uh
and it happened with one of the top
executives of the sony pictures as well
and the person by mistake uh clicked on
the
on the email that he received and that
started with an apple id verification
and
it just
went on to
leave leaking the information about
the apple id information
of that gentleman
as a result a strain of malware called
viper it crippled into the network and
that's where it started from
and when we talk about the impact
the stock prices went down 2.0 one
percent immediately and that's a big
change in the stock market on any given
day
a stock price is stumbling two percent
it's a big big loss to an organization
in a direct financial terms
a lot of embarrassing details came out
publicly related to the hollywood and
the film industry so a lot of
bad publicity
for some of the actors and the actresses
private emails with the
conversation which was not meant to go
public it went public and lot of
distrust started to happen with the sony
pictures and they faced a lawsuit
now
it's not the first time that sony might
have faced
this kind of a situation they were
earlier times as well in 2010 it
happened again
earlier rather and
sony was indeed a target for the
attacker
now
what happened after this breach is that
sony transformed their entire security
infrastructure in a big big way
now when you transform something
it needs a lot of investment
and when we talk about investment it can
be a purchase of a tool it can be
purchased of a technology it can be an
operational expense where you're moving
your infrastructure to the cloud you're
hiring the consultants you're paying the
penalties to the to the regulators
you're hiring consultants to fix things
for you you're hiring the
advocates to to fight your lawsuit in
the code of law as well
so a lot of impact happens which is
direct and indirect as well
now while this was happening the panama
papers came out in 2016.
and uh
there was a leak of about 11.5 million
files that's a big number 11.5 million
files and 2.6 terabyte of information of
the data
went out again in the public domain
about 400 journalists from 107 media
organization in in 80 countries
received and analyzed the leaked
documents
detailing the operations of the law firm
and its client shell companies as well
now
obviously this is something which is
very very private to an individual in
terms of
what investment i have how much wealth i
have
what kind of investments or the assets i
have
if this information goes in public
obviously the public reputation of the
individual would be at the stake but at
the same time
it is much more to do and in the
capacity of an individual if it's a
politician
that there's a there's a trust factor
which is there and that trust factor
would
be impacted when the
information comes in the public that the
politician has made a lot of wealth
without the knowledge of
the fellow politicians or without the
information to the party
now
this is like a big breeze that happened
why it happened what went wrong behind
the scenes is
it happened because of the unpatched
server software and when we talk about
the server software we all know that
patching needs to happen
we all know that matching is one bare
minimum or a basic requirement for any
organization to focus upon but yet
if we read through a verizon's data
breach investigation report year on year
patching has been a challenge for the
organization
they are
covering the patch
with
the workarounds
but then the real patching is not up to
the mark and it indeed is a problem even
today while we are talking about it
so the vulnerable software had more than
25 exploitable vulnerabilities
and this is the exploitable
vulnerabilities there might be
vulnerabilities which are much more
beyond the number 25 but then
those are not exploitable so who cares
for it but then if you club those
vulnerabilities together then we should
care about it
so the first line of defense
which is firewall
was missing
which means
the infrastructure that they had
installed on
the security purposes
was very very minimal
so the investment on the security was
very minuscule from that perspective
so vulnerable systems were placed in the
same network along with the other system
so if i know that i have a vulnerability
i have a weakness in my network i would
probably try to ring fence it i would
try to secure it but then the mistake
that they did
indeed was putting that vulnerable piece
of system into a network and
exposing it with all the filtering rules
because there is no firewall so there
are it's a open invitation for anybody
to make an attempt of intrusion into it
that kind of an impact can happen
uh at a breach level and again if you
look at the impact the leaders
celebrities high profile individuals all
of them came under the scrutiny of this
task
brand reputation reputation loss
happened
uh leading to the loss in the customer
confident in the future business as well
termination of the existing contracts
happened and all of this
sums up to the big drop in the market
for phenomenal papers too
so that's an impact we're talking about
and similar things if we
look into the future and learn from it
electrocard has faced 45 million dollar
yeast
in may 2013 target faced 110 million
credit card
being stolen in the year 2013 again 2017
we have seen equifax
getting compromised with the personal
information of its 148 million consumers
going into the public domain again
now if you look at the
weaknesses that they had
outdated unpatched operating system
attributable to a patch management
outdated antivirus definition kind of a
patch management
not adequately staffed for the security
operation now this is something which is
very important
and this is one of the breaches that i
investigated at that time as well
now what happened in this
they had the security infrastructure
top-notch security infrastructure team
was there
but they were unaware of how to use
those softwares as well
so the awareness the training plays a
very very vital role
in framing up
your security strategy for an
organization too
today we are using the cloud environment
and it is still wide open for with lot
of information
being available in the s3 buckets
right so
open storage systems are there and uh
those are like live available for
anybody to analyze and see what benefit
it has
for them so guessable passwords for
their default passwords were there
direct access to the database from the
administrative desktop was there it was
all fixed up but then these were the
weaknesses that electrocard had
and what electrocard businesses
they were the payment providers of the
payment
uh financial payment processes
for
multiple banks in india and abroad
so what if let's say my services are
being provided by electrocard for an sbi
and i'm a consumer of sbi
if electrocard goes for the toss
it's a sbi literally going for the toss
as well
depending upon the services that they
have taken with them
so
depending upon whether they have a debit
card management system whether they have
a payment processing module with them
whether they have the credit card uh
processing module with them
it's up to an sbi and electrocard to
make sure that the information or the
consumer or the card information needs
to be safeguarded
what happened in the target is the
default password for the bmc performance
assurance portal was weak
it got compromised and from there they
got access to the entire infrastructure
the breach response window was high
and this again boils down to the
responsiveness
or the seriousness of
the team who is handling the security
affairs in the organization
in this particular case the
the india-based sock team a security
operations team
they were able to identify
an anomaly in the pattern or the traffic
that that was going out or getting
exfiltrated from the organization they
identified that on time but then they
were late on responding uh to the u.s
counterparts and they were even late in
responding to the request that came from
the
indian counterparts resulting in a 20
gb of data going out
and that was a big number
equifax again if i look at it
the patch management indeed was a
problem
usage of the legacy system
uh lack of security monitoring expired
ssl certificates guessable passwords
lack of fraud monitoring systems and
processes
these were few
weaknesses that they had
now when we talk about the usage of
legacy systems i can tell you even today
organizations use windows xp to run
their production environment
right so that's the kind of environment
we are living in
while the technology
plays
the the organization's invest on
improving the overall stature of the
security
it comes with its own liabilities as
well so it comes with its own perks and
the liabilities and when we talk about
the liabilities we are talking about the
penalties as well
under gdpr
if an organization doesn't follow or
violate a gdpr
they are exposing themselves to a four
percent of the global revenue
and it's a revenue not the profits and
it's a global revenue not a localized
revenue
so if an organization breaches the
conduct of gdpr they are exposing to a
four percent of the global revenue which
again translates into a huge number for
any organization of any size
if you doesn't follow the regulations
available in netherlands ten percent of
the yearly revenue is what you are
putting at a stake
indian idea act
proposes a three years of imprisonment
for the
execs and from a singapore cyber
security act perspective it's us one
uh
i would say one lakh dollar which is
hundred thousand dollars
and two years of imprisonment to the
execs
and if you look at the map below
that's the
kind of regulatory environment we are
talking about so irrespective where you
want to operate your business
you need to be aware where your
consumers are where is your consumer
base and depending upon your consumer
base you are obliged to follow
the regulations of that particular
geography of that particular country
and if you don't
that's the penalty that you are talking
about these are the liabilities you have
and we have talked about the damages
earlier just to bring a point of view
there
business disruption remediation costs
regulatory sanctions
customer reversal
all of these are the direct costs
when we talk about the indirect cost
the insurance premium that an
organization would pay for their cyber
race
that will go up
that's an indirect cost
customer frauds that can happen
and it's
it's an indirect cost to to the to the
banks
class action lawsuits that can happen to
any organization and which can put your
organization into jeopardy as well and
which can seize your operation business
as well
so class action lawsuits happen
i remember i was working with one of the
bpo organization and
under a contract they were not allowed
and when i say contract they have they
had a contract with one of the antivirus
organization
to support their product
now while supporting they got engaged
into a malpractice where they created an
antivirus of their own
and they started to upsell
the antivirus and other services
to this contracted customers or the
organization's customer base
when it came to limelight first of all
the contract got cancelled there were
penalties being put
for the
uh
for non-adherence of the contracted
terms
plus there was a lot of law action
uh suits that was that got filed in the
united states in the washington state in
the us
and uh apparently this organization had
to shut down the business because of
the law action suits that they they were
unable to manage the cost there so they
had to literally seize the operation and
shut down the shop
so that can be an indirect cost as well
and it's very big
from an intangible cost as well
an irreparable damage to brand can
happen
its rule can happen people would be
asked to leave can be asked to leave as
well
that's something that we saw in the
targets uh cases well where ceo and the
cto lost their job because they were
unable to respond to the notification
that came from the india counterparts
a competitive disadvantage can happen if
my
intellectual property gets lost or if my
classified business plan gets leaked out
that can have an a competitive
disadvantage to me and competitive
advantage to the other firm as well and
i will lose on the opportunity
cost or the opportunity price that i
probably would have gained
so these are some of the intangible cost
that can
that can be seen from a damages
perspective as well
so a lot of scary thing that can happen
so
unfortunately we have to live with it
even today
but then what we can do to make this
secure
right and when we talk about making it
secure it is important for us to look at
the industry trends as well
where the trends are going
and what is the response which is needed
to address those trends
and when we talk about those trends
verizon dbir is the best place where we
can go and look out for the trends
because the data that they have is a
consolidated data year on year
based on the live breaches that they
have investigated
and also
the breaches that their partner
organizations have seen and they have
shared the anonymous data with them
now looking at the trends if you look at
uh there are some six trends that we're
talking about here
and if you look at the first break or
the first pillar we are talking about
phishing as the top database data breach
tactic for 2021.
i still remember in 2015 they came out
with a dbir wherein they indicated that
phishing is increasing
and when we talk about of this phishing
trend in 2022 looking at the data of
2021
we see that 36
of the data breaches
have happened because of the phishing
and which is an increase of 11 percent
from the further 20 20 year
right so
that's a trend that we are talking about
in a fishing parlance
when we talk about the second pillar
it's about having an 85 percent of the
breaches
talking about or getting a human element
involved into it and when we are talking
about a human element
it can be a security misconfiguration
because of an unawareness it can be a
social engineering again a targeted
attempt that can happen or an individual
diverging some information by mistake
so those kind of numbers can contribute
to 85 percent of the data breaches and
these are all true numbers
that has been reported
when we talk about the third vertical
what we see that
from a financial terms perspective
there are two key terms which are being
most talked about
in the public forums
and in the dark web as well
and these two terms were bank account
credit card
these two terms are totally financially
relatable
and that causes a lot of concern
obviously from a security standpoint
if you look at the fourth pillar it
talks about the
discovery of the vulnerabilities where
eighty percent of the vulnerabilities
were reported and discovered by the
external parties which means
eighty percent of the vulnerabilities
were not detected by the organization
and why not
because of the lack of skills
and that is where it becomes important
for an organization to hire the right
talent
and
that's what we are going to do to
improve in ourselves into the career of
security as well
from a social engineering standpoint
35 percent of the breaches were because
of social engineering
and it is it has seen an increase of 22
percent
over 2022 results
and when we are talking about social
engineering
people have really made fortunes in
kovaid situation as well where the
phishing or the social engineering
attempts have started to focus
unfortunately on the topic of coven 19
as well you need a vaccination register
here i can help you give me the money i
will help you with the uh with the
vaccination here is a 4v19 form please
go ahead and fill this up with your
organization credentials and you will
win a lottery out of it
we will give you a vaccination and so on
so those kind of situations is what we
have seen
increasing from a trend that we see in
year 2021 in the dbir results
the last pillar
is all about the targeted data
we're talking about the credentials we
are talking about the personal data
we're talking about the bank data we are
talking about the internal
organizational data as well
which is being targeted so a lot of
information
is available in terms of
how the industry is shaping up in terms
of what needs to be protected now if i
look at this
one key theme is we need to be aware
second we need to spread awareness
thirdly we need to be educated enough to
protect the organization and fourth we
need to implement the technology the
tools the processes the administrative
roles
in order to prevent the organization
from getting peace
and while we are talking about all of
this
there is something that we need to be
aware about
where do we want to head our career into
do we want to grow into cloud security
do we want to grow into compliance
do we want to grow into a threat and
vulnerability management where we can
become the pen testers as well or the
exploit writers or the developers too or
do we want to grow ourselves into cyber
six
different streams require different
focus areas but then one thing or three
things that all of these streams or any
of these streams would require is a
focus patience and persistence
if you don't have either of it
you cannot be
you cannot grow into a cyber security
field
or for that matter any other field as
well so focus patience and persistence
is necessary absolutely necessary
non-negotiable
but other than that what technical
skills do you need
do you know windows operating systems
how it works at a server level at an end
point level you need to know the
internals of the os
do you know how unix or linux works a
lot of the workloads that we have today
on the cloud environment a lot of uh
organizations are moving towards and
adopting the unix
so
a lot of organizations are working
towards it do you know that operating
system how it functions how to manage it
how to administer the security features
of it if not probably that's the area
that we need to learn
network devices firewalls switches hubs
databases
if i am working for an organization
where i am responsible for ensuring a
security posture
for an application
i should know how to secure database 2.
i should know how to secure tomcat for
that matter i should know how to secure
apache for that matter of api for that
matter or a log structure for that
matter
do i know a fundamentals of tcp ip or
the communication protocols if not
that's
bare minimum information that i
shouldn't be aware about
then if you want to grow into cyber
forensics
or the incident investigation kind of a
field
then a skill on or the knowledge on the
forensics tool set is also required and
you should practice to have that mindset
of the forensics investigator too
and last but not least
is how clear you can communicate
what information you're focusing while
communication and how good you are at a
documentation as well because if you
know and you cannot translate that on a
piece of paper
or you're losing it
so looking at a
cyber security from a career standpoint
what are the things that you can become
you can be a threat hunter purple team
i'm a person you can be into ics ot
security consultant cloud security
analyst cyber security analyst all of
this you can become these are different
streams that you can pick up start
focusing into these streams
and i'm sure you will grow
into those areas as well
what kind of organizations do these
individuals gets hired into
consulting is one area which requires
probably each one of this
in all these blocks you would find a
space in a consulting organization
because i come from that background so i
can resonate my experience with that
enterprises again
most of these boxes you can fill it up
if you
uh looking at a if you're looking at a
requirement from an enterprise
standpoint
even in the manufacturing you will have
a good enough requirement from an ics ot
security consultant application pen
tester
perspective or synt investigator
perspective stock analyst all of these
blocks would go into a manufacturing
sector because they are dealing with the
critical assets
from a health care perspective
you can fill most of it
uh so
that's
that's the kind of an influence the
healthcare industry has
itits take all the boxes it is as good
as the consulting now so take all the
boxes and that's the requirement of an
itits organization financial
again
take almost all the boxes barring ics ot
security consultant probably or
probably a you know kind of
purple teamer they would probably go
with the red teamer
so depending upon the industry
these boxes
are something that you can become
in the near future as well once you
start to invest on your learning
if you stop learning
you are stagnant and if you're stagnant
you're not growing if you're not growing
cyber security is not the path
so it is important for us to
be a good individual
be aware
learn and implement and all of these
sectors that we talked about
are hiring in a big big time
and when i say a big time it is really a
big time where
specifically if i talk about the
consulting organization they do projects
with literally all of these sectors and
even beyond
and when they do projects it can be a
short-term project it can be a long-term
project as well when i talk about the
enterprises for that matter
they are dealing with the plethora of
information within the organization
which is cutting across the boundaries
they are working on the applications
which is posted let's say in in
netherlands but then
is accessible over the internet to all
the countries
take an example of a shell petrol punk
they have
they have the shell app you can go there
on the points
and those points are equivalent to
rupees as well or the the currency that
you have
so you have
those kind of
organizations
which are not dealing directly in the
money side into a monetary side but at
the same time
they do have something which is of equal
importance to the consumer
and that's where i'm saying
cyber security as a career path is ever
growing
it is not going to stop here
it is ever expanding and it will
continue to expand
and with that i will open up for a q a
and anything that you want to ask me
okay and we have a bunch of questions
that have come in for us perfect
uh
so
one question that's common to several uh
of our audience members is is it
necessary to learn any kind of
programming language to learn cyber
security
uh well i will just go back to my slide
number this
now
when we talk about a programming
language
if we are looking to become an
application pen tester
which is
this block
or if you are talking about
becoming a vulnerability researcher
which is this block
then yes you should be aware about the
coding language but if you are
trying to get into a role of a cloud
security analyst
you should be aware but you may not be
an expert into it
for example if you're talking about a
malware analyst until unless i know how
to code i would not be able to develop a
malware
but yes if i am into a digital forensics
probably i would invest a lot of time in
understanding the operating system
rather than learning a language
so depending upon the nature of the job
that i am picking up or the field that i
am picking up
it will have its own course of learning
it will have its own course of education
it will have its own course of
certifications as well
and i hope that answers
yes
um
myanch and a few other people are asking
about
the best entry point for someone who
wants to get into
a cyber security career
wonderful question and i think that's
very really went to this topic as well
that we are discussing today and
i can say as an entry point
when we are looking to start our career
into it first and foremost is to
understand the concept of security and
if we do that
rather let's
look at how should we start it
so the way i started let let me share
that experience so i started with uh
reading through an nist
800 series special publication on the
risk management i learned it i still
remember that
very very thoroughly because that was
the first document that i read in the
field of security
then i started my journey into iso 27001
iso 27005
and then i realized it's more of a
compliance
and then i ventured into a technical
side of security
but by doing a technology plus the
framework plus the awareness on the
standards
i was able to
create a complete picture of the
security circle
and that helped me landing myself into
the role
with a small time company at that time
and that helped me in growing as well uh
in where i am today so to start your
career
be aware of the frameworks read through
it it has a lot of information wealth of
information
uh focus on the box that you want to
focus upon so if you want to be a
digital forensics analyst look out for
the certifications that you can clear
look out for the courses that you can do
on this
and then eventually start looking out
for the opportunities in that area as
well and for sure if you learn it well
if the content is good that you're
learning from you will definitely get a
job there
okay
sadarshan has a question about uh
if you're good at social engineering um
where would you fit into this
matrix of jobs
wow
so if i am a social engineering person i
would go into an ocean investigator
which is like the
mostly relatable to a social engineering
i would look myself into a threat hunter
as well
though it is technical not purely
relatable to a social engineering but
then if if we look at the verizon
results fishing and social engineering
are topping it up
so there's a threat on the individuals
as well
i would become
uh if from a social engineering
perspective i can go into a red teamer
as well
because there's a lot of social
engineering tactics that gets utilized
when you are a red teamer
and obviously that's only one component
of it you would
obviously be looking at a technology
stack you would be looking at a malware
stack as well but then the entry point
if if i look at the entire kill chain or
a cyber kill chain what we call it
it has the payload you have created but
then it has to be delivered
and until it unless i am unable to
deliver my payload or a malware to the
target
i'm not a good red teamer so red team is
a good starting point for a social
engineering
enthusiast as well
okay
we have
a question from the youtube audience
in fact we have a couple of interesting
questions that are related deficient and
a person goes by er
both have uh backgrounds outside of
it so deep fish is a mechanical
engineering student
and
er is an insurance rep for an auto
insurance company with no tech
background but both of them
um are interested um er has taken the
comp tia certification
and d fish is learning linux and python
so
what
roadmap would you suggest they follow
and what certifications would you
suggest they go uh
perfect
to develop their careers
perfect so uh i couldn't get but i can
tell you the person who is doing a linux
and a python so let me just take his
example first
so when i started my career i was i
started itself with a help desk
experience
so i was the one with
with the screwdriver in hand and i would
rip apart the laptops the desktops clean
it up assemble it back and give it to
the customer back that's the profile
that i started with
then
i landed myself into a system
administration and something that
that i can relate with the experience
that the person is saying that they are
doing a linux and the python so i
started and landed myself into that zone
where i was a system administrator for a
decent amount of years
i did development
as well so i used to code on python and
perl as the two primary languages
and that gave me an insight about how
operating system functions
i was able to understand what are some
of the vulnerabilities that an operating
system
has and how i can exploit it
i learned that from a system
administration perspective from a
development perspective
i understood what are some of the
quick fixes that developers do
from where they copy the code from where
they paste it how they use it so i know
the vulnerabilities in the human as well
or the human psyche for that matter
i was able to appreciate the language as
well from the perspective of the
security protocols or the security
functions that it provides and
that helped really
that helped me in
clearing the interviews that i was
appearing at that time
and even today i think the journey of
security doesn't start with security it
starts with understanding the
infrastructure so if you are learning
the infrastructure correctly if you have
a red hat certification for example
then you are on a right track to
understand the operating system linux
and then if you are growing into a
security and focusing on the technology
as a career path in the cyber security
as well
focus on getting something from an oscp
kind of a certification or oswp as a
wireless
professional certification as well so
look at these certifications which are
giving you a practical exposure as well
look at the ecppt for example which is
giving you a hands-on experience on
application
now coming to the other gentleman who is
into an insurance sector
now since insurance is very relatable to
a protocol
a regulation that an organization should
follow under let's say in india we have
the irda regulator which is more into
the insurance regulation
for that individual it will be
prudent to say
the person should focus on the
compliance and the framework as the
career
wherein the person is focusing and doing
the
or understanding the nist or doing the
certification which are related to iso
27001 learning cissp for that matter
and i can i myself has taken a course
from simply learn on cissp and i am
proudly
saying that i am cissp certified today
so
uh so cissp indeed is a very good course
that the er uh can really look for and
he can be a best suited there
individually
um we have a couple of questions about
how
or what uh certifications or what path
will get you into cloud security
so from a cloud standpoint
there are different paths that you can
look at
you can be an architect
you can be an analyst you can be
a
kind of incident response team member
from a cloud perspective you can be an
identity administrator
as well so depending upon the path that
you are looking for
you should first get a fundamentals
clear on the cloud so cloud fundamental
is bare minimum
then
starting with that cloud fundamental you
should
look out if you're looking for from a
job perspective
and if you're targeting a particular
cloud environment look out for the
certifications that they have in the
path
for example if you're looking for aws or
amazon web services so look out for the
certifications which can lead to a
security architect
role
and in that journey you would get a lot
of clarification in terms of the
environment the integrations that they
have the services that they offer the
product they have
and once you are aware about all those
product
you can then pick one product and be a
special or a specialist in that
particular product similarly for azure
you have a lot of certifications which
are available
so look at for look out for the interest
that you have in the in the cloud
environment
and then start to pick up a product
based certification so
i can tell you if you are doing an
identity as a theme for your
certification
cloud is revolving around it
so
look out the look out for the identity
as
the as a stream for you to grow in and
do a certification which resonates with
the identity as a team
that relates to a question from amit who
asks about uh he was advised to look
into iam
and specifically
to get into
cyber security through the identity and
access path
and
do you think he was given good advice
and and
what other
certifications can take them further
along that path or into other areas
and i can tell you octa is one product
which is uh which is there and it is one
of the leading product as well in the
industry so if you are focusing on the
octa as the product
continue to do that and look out for the
opportunities because
uh it is not one product which is going
to stay there in the identity space you
have cyber arc for example so look out
for the certifications in the cyber arc
which is common across the platform
and do a certification on cyber art
there are a lot of caspy products which
are available so
look out for a mix of products uh don't
stay with one product is what my advice
to you
because uh then you are not becoming a
product agnostic
so when we talk about cyber security it
is about industry not how how industry
agnostic you are and how much product
agnostic you are
so uh don't stay with one product octa
definitely is one of the good product
and you should continue to invest in
octa but at the same time look out for
the opportunities where you can learn
let's say cyber arc as well
yeah because there's no guarantee that a
particular product is going to
absolutely survive forever um
so
we have a
member of the audience bieswa who has
asked a question
and
it's in the form of a number of
different topics that he's interested in
and you can tell
tell him what area
would be the best for him he's he wants
to know about emote he wants to know
about denial of service about man in the
middle about phishing
sql injection and password attacks
so what does what does he sound like to
you in terms of
cyber security
i would say he is more getting into a
penetration penetration testing side
and uh when i talk about a penetration
tester he can be a ocean investigator he
can be an application pentester and he
can be a vulnerability researcher and a
red teamer as well so a lot of fields
that he can pick up
and when we are talking about
the intrusions when we are talking about
exploits when we are talking about
writing and executing a code it's all
relatable when we are talking about the
products like metasploit or the
wireshark anything of that sort it's all
pen testing so i think these are four
blocks that he can start to pick up
and just to be uh
from my own
edification
red teaming and
certified ethical hacking are similar
no
so oh okay so
when we talk about as uh ethical hacking
it's like you have a permission and
there is a scope which is defined for
you
and you are following that scope so for
example
you have
a bank website
and as an ethical hacker you are allowed
to test that website only
whereas as a red teamer you're actually
acting as a hacker
there is no boundary there is no scope
yes there is a agreement that gets
signed between the two entities but then
you are free to do whatever you want
the output should be
a impact
on the organization whether you are able
to exfiltrate the data of out of the
organizational boundaries or not or
whether you are able to plant your
exploit in the environment or not
the
impact is different in both the
perspectives
thank you because that clarifies it in
my mind i was i was confused between the
two
um
we have reached uh
more than an hour we're at almost an
hour and a quarter and i have to
apologize to
everybody whose questions i have not
been able to get to there have been
hundreds
and i apologize again for not being able
to
take them all but
i do want to thank you
for us for for your generosity with your
time we're going to move on from here to
the closing of the webinar so
let me
ahead and take back the sharing
privilege
and
i'll finish off
the webinar from here
and i do want to um
ask one exit poll for folks
regarding the
areas that are most of interest to you
so let me do that
as soon as we get the sharing guy
and this poll has to do with which areas
are most interesting you in the audience
you can
select one or more
um
what are the areas in in cyber security
that
of of the ones that
person mentioned
that most
appeal to you
yeah i've got about 10 more seconds on
the poll
all right
and it's very interesting poll result
because as we see
people are interested in all the areas
except compliance not quite so much
and it's encouraging to see as about a
third of the audience is interested in
starting their city's studies right away
so
with that let's move on and i want to
say thank you again to peras for being
here this has been
just a wonderful session and i'm going
to drop into the chat um
his linkedin information so that you can
reach out to him
i'm also going to drop into the chat
information about the courses
that simply learn offers
and you can reach out to us for that
both through our website as well as
through
our
learning consultants i'll give you their
email address
the first the linkedin
connection for
dr aurora
and then
here is a web link and an email address
that will let you
find out more about simple learns
courses and programs the certifications
we offer
programs we even offer with
institutions like mit in the us and iiit
in bangalore
and
with that
i also want to mention the
next webinar
which will be next tuesday in a
different field this is about machine
intelligence
and it's an interesting topic because um
going to speak about
the evolution of
machine intelligence
4.0
and the impact that will have on
technical careers both within ai and ml
but also in other areas so
with that
with that i'm going to conclude the
webinar
i want to say thank you to everybody
who has attended
and
we'll be finished
so again i'm sorry for the
blank
no worries to it and thank you so much
for having me here and i want to
personally thank each and every
participant as well for asking those
relevant and
very interesting questions
and i still while we are talking i still
see a lot of questions being pouring in
so that's encouraging as well
uh so happy to connect over linkedin
with all of you and uh yeah stay
connected and stay safe
okay great thank you so much and and um
i'd encourage everyone to to
reach out to for us
um i want to thank everybody in the
audience for being here i encourage you
to reach out to us
uh through the links i shared but also
on facebook twitter and linkedin you can
reach us at simplylearn
thank you so much and that concludes our
webinar for today
all right thank you everyone take care
bye
bye
you